now that new edition of shark tank you
in life we got to entrence ready to go
head-to-head Kevin over there can shark
tank II here we've already seen a double
dutch it's one of his many many talents
also wearing that sommelier z-- cup all
about wine and you guys have a big
launch coming up that started at shark
cave
yeah it's the largest nail ever done in
Shark Tank history 2.5 million dollars
it's mine it's about changing the wine
industry the only beverage in America
that we can't buy in a single serve is
wine and to do it yeah I'm a huge wine
lover George that five sellers I'm a
member of the chef of a detective I
collect wine I love it I've decided to
launch my own wine in conjunction with
launching the new technology and single
serve so O'Leary wines is being launched
on QVC April 26 and then it's going
online and then at the end of May we're
launching single serve so when you go to
a rock show or you go to a baseball game
football game single serve of wine in a
plastic container never been done before
I think it's going to be huge we feel on
Shark Tank today that we're big enough
now as a platform to change and innovate
industries cannot wait to see that